Багато людей якось відсторонилося.
Відбулося певне відмежування від природи,
коли ми себе відсторонили і не бачимо,
що ми є частиною цієї природи.
Певною мірою, екологічний активізм —
це пробудитися і відродити почуття спільності.
Так, нам треба відра.
Це будуть відкриті водойми.
Ну, п'ять хай буде, про всяк випадок.
— Все?
— Так.
— А я йду з вами, так?
Експедиція «Екодія. У пошуках чистої води» —
це перша експедиція нашої організації.
З місією — перевірити воду в десяти сільських
громадах в Україні в десяти областях.
Ми подорожуємо з півночі на південь,
у двох басейнах двох річок.
Це Дніпро і Південний Буг.
Ми вимірюємо якість води за базовими
фізико-хімічними показниками.
Ми вимірюємо якість води в криницях,
свердловинах і відкритих водоймах.
— Там риба якась підозріла, дуже велика.
— Так.
[спілкуються між собою]
Спершу вимірюємо температуру
середовища і розчинений кисень.
Це показник, який важливий для відкритих водойм,
як-от річки, канали, озера.
Зараз якраз його перевіряємо першим.
Раз, два, три, чотири, п'ять, шість.
Тримай.
Фактично скрізь, де ми бували,
всі масово жаліються на те,
що падає рівень води.
У багатьох криницях він просто вже зник.
І кількість води безпосередньо
пов'язана з якістю води.
Тому що чим менше води,
чим менший її об'єм,
тим більший ризик підвищення
концентрації забруднення.
Питання: як дізнатися ту інформацію?
Тобто ми знаємо напевно, що вони щодня перевіряють,
якщо йдеться про велике місто,
що там щодня це перевіряється і, відповідно,
адаптується, якщо є якісь проблеми.
У сільській місцевості це — децентралізовані джерела.
Тобто ймовірність того, що його взагалі
хтось колись перевіряв, доволі низька.
І це підверджується в нашій експедиції.
Коли ми спілкуємося з власниками криниць
чи свердловин, то запитуємо,
чи колись взагалі хтось перевіряв,
чи ви перевіряли.
Якщо людина самостійно, її родич або друг
не повіз у місто в лабораторію і не здав,
то людина може життя прожити,
не знаючи те, що вона п'є.
У криниці [вода] погана вже стала.
Мало стало.
Свердловина також зараз не дуже...
У кого є більше, у кого менше, у кого як.
А якість колись перевіряли?
Ні. Ніде.
Здається, тоді одразу санстанції
самостійно перевіряли.
Давно вже перевіряли?
Коли приблизно?
Ну, років п'ятнадцять [тому].
Одразу як робили, тоді й перевірили?
Так.
І все нормально було, не казали,
що щось не те?
Наче було нормально.
Хіба не пригадую, бо вже час минув.
Та якби сказали: «Ай-яй-яй, не пийте»,
то запам'ятали б.
А що залишається робити?
Треба ж щось пити.
У нас не розбереш запах.
Вони як зранку свої процедури роблять,
то тут міняється повітря і все...
То від пташників, ви маєте на увазі, так?
Вони постійно як скид роблять,
відчувається [запах].
Звісно, є.
І що ми зробимо?
Нічого не ми зробимо, бо воно вже є.
Займаємося темою біогенного забруднення.
Це ті самі нітрати, фосфати.
Доволі нетипове забруднення.
Тому що воно відбувається на площині,
на величезній точці.
Уявіть, як виглядає поле.
І все це поле може бути
джерелом розсіяного забруднення.
Тому якщо, наприклад, [йдеться про] завод,
то там є якась труба,
в яку можна встановити датчик.
І знати, скільки в конкретній точці викидається.
І це так зване точкове забруднення.
У сільському господарстві,
якщо йдеться про великі поля,
це десятки, сотні або й тисячі гектарів,
куди вносять агрохімікати, пестициди.
Завдання із зірочкою:
промоніторити велику площину і як вона впливає.
За несприятливої погоди є високий ризик того,
що частина всіх цих хімікатів
вимивається або просочується в ґрунт.
Потім потрапляє в ґрунтові води,
далі опускається або ж йде
площинним стоком, змивається.
— Амоній п'ять хвилин.
— Ой, 15.
— 15, окей.
В Україні, насправді, три норми для питної води,
залежно від джерела.
Чи це вода фасована, чи з водопроводу, чи з криниці.
Тобто нормативи для питної води,
як я собі уявляю,
мають відштовхуватися від того,
як та чи інша концентрація впливає на здоров'я.
Ми відштовхуємося від фасованої води,
порівнюючи високий вміст чи ні.
Дивимося на фасовану воду,
тому що в неї найвищі стандарти, найбільш жорсткі,
які багато в чому відповідають європейським
нормативам для питної води.
Якраз така невелика несправедливість
щодо сільських мешканців, на мою думку,
що найнижчі, найслабші нормативи —
для колодязної води.
Наприклад, амоній.
Для фасованої води, покупної води
в пляшках чи з бюветів норматив —
0,1 мг на літр для амонію.
Для колодязів це — 2,6.
Тобто в скільки це разів?
[Різниця] в 26 разів.
У нас виходить, що найбільше
перевищення відбулося по фосфатах.
І це перевищення не в місті, не в Каневі,
а якраз-таки по селах.
Так, це цікаво.
Перше — це аналіз, скринінг.
І неодноразовий,
а важливо робити це системно,
щоби бачити тенденцію.
І від цього вже відштовхуватися.
Також маємо на меті, зрештою,
показати [людям] приклад,
щоб вони побачили, як це робиться,
такими, доволі любительскими методами,
і надихнути їх, насправді, надалі проводити подібний,
вже системний, моніторинг у своїх громадах.
Якраз для цього ми теж зараз
маємо спільнокошт-кампанію,
де ми запрошуємо всіх охочих задонатити нам,
щоби закупити ось такі тест-системи в кожну громаду,
куди їдемо, у ці десять областей.
Щоби групи активістів мали подібні інструменти,
які ми використовуємо,
щоб вони на системному, постійному рівні
з певною періодичністю проводили такі аналізи.
Щоб, знову ж таки, виявити цю тенденцію,
чи ситуація погіршується, чи є стабільною.